amazing you'll never be able to look at
circles the same way after I show you
the way to work out the radius of this
circle I've got something special for
you today I have a sequence of numbers
that I want you to be able to work out
what the next number in the sequence is
these are fractions so it's going to be
one on 15 one on 23 one on 39 one on 63
and then something there are lots of
ways I could show you how to solve this
but today I'm going to show you a very
special way how to solve it okay so
we're just going to put this over here I
need to get some equipment okay I got to
start drawing some circles my goodness
me have you ever have you ever done a
video where it's like the paper itself
has to be precise now I can use my other
precision instrument here my second
circle circle number to look at that
okay so these ones are exactly the same
and they're half the diameter of the big
circle this is going to be fun once we
actually get there that was hard to get
these ones to kiss so they're now
kissing these are kissing circles so
mathematically we'd say that they're
touching tangentially though they're
kissing now oh okay Brady you know hard
it is to get four circles to kiss do you
know how hard that is you know I have to
I have to confess you I've done this a
few times this is the best time I've
done it this blue circle here just so
happens that the radius of this blue
circle here is one fifteenth of this big
circle it's 1:15 hang on
okay let me keep going so this is called
a papist chain what I'm doing here so
having one circle touching the inside of
another circle kissing and then having
circles fitting in and touching all one
another it's a big touch fest today so
these things have been around for a long
time okay so this one here touching
touching touching so this one here this
is this new blue circle this one happens
to be one twenty third of the original
radius one twenty third 115-120 third
this one's good look at that beautiful
it is very zen the next one here this
little guy happens to be one thirty
ninth of the original large circles
there you go I don't know how much more
of this compass I can use okay so this
guy here his radius is 160 third the
original radius of the big circle 163rd
and so what's the next one going to be
well let's draw it in shall we
this here this here now belongs to these
circles and so the question is what is
the radius of this circle in reference
to our first circle now there's plenty
of ways we could actually work that out
we could get busy with our rulers and
start drawing triangles and maybe start
getting angles and maybe start using
different kind of theorems and whatnot
to try and get there but there is one
way to solve this problem which is
absolutely amazing absolutely amazing
great
it is the way to solve this problem what
I'm going to show you is actually
amazingly hard core is a huge amount of
information dealing with this so what
you have to do is I'm going to try and
show you just what we need for this
problem and hopefully you can go and
have a look at all the other stuff in
your own time but this is something that
we just go to Brady F trust me I'm going
to show you exactly what we need for
this problem and no more but if your
imagination is fired up that's because
you're thinking that's good the way to
solve this problem is using a method
called circle inversion there's a quick
introduction I think most people have
seen a reflection of themselves correct
so if you think about that you've got
your eyeball here so here's your eyeball
so now you know how reflections work
right so what you see is the mirror
opposite but what actually is going on
is it's this distance here 22 we're
going to do this quite rough Brady if
that's all right okay we know how
mirrors work don't we so over this it's
the eyeball it's your eyeball looking
back at you right this is called a
reflection so we're going to do a
special type of reflection to solve this
problem it's called a circle inversion
okay now this is how it works first off
you got to start with a circle so this
circle here we're going to be it's our
circle of inversion so first of all what
we need to do is we need to what we need
to know the radius that's really
important Brady okay
so in this case here the radius is 60
say we put a point out here okay so say
we put a point here okay and that point
there is going to be a and this point
here is o 4 origin so now we did a
reflection what happens in inversion is
first of all we're going to measure oh a
so we know how a equals 30 so this point
here we're actually going to invert it
and this is how you do it
you take this length here right which we
know is 30 and you multiply by the point
we're going to we don't know where it is
just yet and it equals the circle radius
squared so this equals 60 squared so in
this case this is 30 times where we want
to go equals 60 squared so if we just
divide through and do a quick little bit
of calculation then that goes twice so
that means equals 120 and so what that
what we've done there is we've actually
taken this point all the way out on
exactly the same line to here so this
length here is Oh a dash and it equals
120 and this length here is okay
and that equals 30 so 30 times 120
equals the radius squared so this point
has been inverted to this point so
whether you're inside the circle you go
to the outside and if you're outside you
go to the inside and it's all based on
this these formulas so that's it that
circle inversion you want to see what
circle inversion can do in please right
so I've just drawn a circle within my
circle of inversion so we've only
inverted one point what happens to all
the points the infinite number of points
in a circle when you do the same process
okay so we're going to take that circle
and invert it we're going to invert the
circle that's right so what do you think
is going to happen to all these points
tell me well my instinct yeah is that
you draw another circle out out here
somewhere out in the in the great beyond
is going to be circular that would be my
instinct not an oval my instinct is will
be another circle G you've got good
instincts
so this point here has been inverted to
that point there so you can see the
closer it is to the circle of inversion
the closer it is on the other side so
cave divide that O'Brady so we haven't
planned this very well this is huge
so cos this one is here this inverts out
all the way to here so this has already
got some very unusual properties right
Wow look at this we've actually gone
over the original and we're all over the
place with this one this is huge so it's
different to a reflection where this
where it's not scaled but this in a
sense is scaled this inverts to this and
what you'll find is that you'll get
these points on the edge you see that
where they're both touching there'll be
one point where they touch both here and
here at one point where they touch over
here and here okay if we measure this
length and times it by that length
we'll get 60 squared okay so what
happens is a circle will invert to
another circle okay and we don't have to
do this because we showed before the
points go back so if we started with
this circle on the outside it had come
back to this one now the other thing
that you need to know is that this is
true as well if the circle happens to
overlap the circle of inversion so you
could think what happens if the circle
that we're inverting what happens to
this circle Brady well we still get a
circle well we will we definitely still
get a circle this point if this is a
little important of invert to a point
there is only a fraction in what yeah
exactly that's going to start there and
come out big yep but what's the two
points we've already seen on the circle
can you see two points that we already
know are going to be on this inverted
circle the ones that touch the line the
ones that intersect the line exactly so
you can you see there Brady we've done a
inversion circle and it's crossed here
it's crossed here kind of
a little bit there but you can see that
it still makes another circle now is one
more I'm going to show you is one more I
got to show you I can I just say it's
important that you prove these things to
yourself but I'm not going to prove them
today I'll show you this because this
one this one's weird and what about a
circle that actually passes through the
origin well think about it well if
there's a point on the origin right
what's the length from the origin if
you're at the origin zero so in really
it's going to blow up so points that get
very very close to the origin are going
to get huge towards infinity so we're
really talking about a massive circle
here and you know how massive it just
looks like a line so any circle that
passes through the origin of the circle
inversion will invert to a line and lo
and behold check it out look at that so
circle inversion amazing look at the
properties circles invert two circles
okay
big goes to small small goes to big if a
circle crosses the circle of inversion
it still looks like a circle and then I
think most stunning of all a circle that
passes through the origin will invert to
a straight line so this is all we need
these two facts will kind of fact 1a and
1b and then fact two okay that's all we
need so now with our information about
circle inversion how can we actually
solve this problem well what we need to
do first we need to make a decision
about what sort of circle we're actually
going to use to invert the way to solve
this is to get this bad boy again and
what we're going to do is we're actually
going to do a circle of inversion that
is exactly the same as our original
circle okay so this is our original
circle we're going to put the origin of
our circle of inversion right at the end
so this this green dotted line is our
Circle of inversion and this is what
we're going to do all our work with okay
so this is our circle of inversion and
remember it's got exactly the same
radius as our original circle that's
important now
remember what I said Brady what are the
what are the things that we need to know
about inversions we need to know circles
invert two circles if they go over the
same over the circle of inversion they
still in virtuous circles unless part of
the circle goes through the center of
origin of the circle of inversion then
it turns into straight wrong bingo now
this is the reason why I came because
now I am able to invert these circles
and just using a ruler right I'm able to
Mabel to show you how beautiful how
simple it is now to interpret this
problem this big circle here Brady this
big circle here what does it invert -
well first of all it passes through the
center of inversion so we know it coz is
going to turn into a straight line now
where is that straight line going to be
well you know what I don't have to
calculate anything because I already
know that it intersects the circle of
inversion there so this is the radius so
this point goes back to itself so we
know that this point is on the straight
line because it intersects the circle of
inversion I know what the other one is -
where exactly so straight away you only
need two points to the final line yeah
so that we we know we can actually just
really simply draw this in we've
just put a our first inverted circle
next what about this circle here so this
circle here also passes through the
center of origin but it kisses the
inside it kisses the inside of the
inversion circle now that means it's
going to invert to a straight line
exactly but where is it going to be is
it going to be a straight line like that
or like that well let's have a look this
circle here okay and this circle here
are both going to invert two straight
lines but they only touch at the point
of origin and that point of origin in
effect is infinity so if two lines only
touch at infinity well this is kind of
tricky stuff here that's parallel that's
the only that's the only explanation
really isn't it so you see the logic
that you can draw out of just these
simple rules of circles go to circles
the logic here is that well if it goes
anything else it will eventually hit
which means that point must be an
intersecting point back here but we know
that doesn't happen because there's
origin point so you can deductively
reason what happens here okay Brady so
this big circle is this one and this
circle is this one now what happens to
this circle here well again we don't
have to measure anything this circle
here touches the big circle and touches
this circle and we already know that
this circle is that line and this circle
is that line so this has to be touching
both this and this and so really there's
only one thing it can be if a circle
inverts to a circle it has to be a
circle that fits between these parallel
lines well let's draw that in Brady
this has happened to there this point
hasn't moved because it's on the circle
of inversion but a circle has inverted
to a circle now what about this guy here
how do we invert this one well straight
away we know that two points have to be
here and here because they invert well
they're on the circle of inversion
where's another point well this one here
is on this circle here and even though
it actually in in this diagram it
actually is on it an inverted circle we
have to remember that that's not where
it's going it's actually going to here
okay this guy here these two touch right
there so this is touching this circle
this circle of this circle I think you
should be able to see what's going on
now if this circle is touching this
circle this circle and this circle then
in the inversion these two circles
aligns this circle is here this has to
touch that that and that
which means it has to be another a
circle exactly the same radius exactly
the same diameter see how much symmetry
there is how beautiful this is how
awesome this is Brady I mean this the
symmetry of this is just breathtaking in
the inverted world we still get kissing
okay now Brady there's another circle
this blue one here this is the guy here
which is one fifteenth of the original
radius is what I told you now we
actually have to invert this guy so this
circle is that circle this circle is
that circle this circle is actually over
here so that circles there so this guy
in here is kissing one two three and of
these purples it's one two three so we
know that this blue guy has to actually
be in here has to touch all three so is
it a rule that if you kiss in real life
you have to kiss
exactly now this little circle is the
inversion of the blue circle what about
the one that we really want this one
down here how do we get there
well we've inverted one two we're going
to invert this guy now so this guy
inverts and you know what it's becoming
so simple to do because we know that
it's a circle that has to touch this guy
here so this is touching this and this
is this so this circle has to touch here
is touching the big circle which we know
is that line you know it's such in this
circle it's that line so it's just a
straightforward process
where we now have to just draw circles
in one on top of another
this Pappas chain of circles getting
progressively smaller and smaller and
smaller under inversion ends up being
circles stacked on top of each other
exactly the same radius exactly the same
diameter because they're fitting between
two parallel lines so this is absolutely
beautiful this is this one this is this
one this is this one this is this one
this is this one so now if we think
about it in the Pappas chain the blue
guys are touching these circles and
touching this circle here so in the
inversion okay we've already seen that
this blue circle inverts here so the
pattern is going to stay the same
there's going to be a circle there it's
going to be a circle there they're going
to circle the other than T so for their
circle bit and all going to be exactly
the same size okay so if we can work out
the diameter of this we can work out the
diameter of this and then we've got the
radius so how can we do that this is
epic this is seriously epic all right
here we go so we've got now this is a
right angle and we know that this circle
here even though that's so tiny the
center of this circle will pass through
the center of this circle up here
we now have a massive right angle
triangle if we know this length here we
can invert that length and it will give
us the length through this circle and
because it's passing through the origin
of this little circle it will tell us
the diameter and if we divide that by
two it will tell us the radius so shall
we do it let's bring this home I tell
you what this is absolutely epic
it's very pretty though this whole this
whole length here is our it's the circle
of inversion so this half here is going
to be our on to right and this length
here
well this circle here is a half of that
so right from here to here that's our
own four and this this little blue
inverted circle here is a quarter of
that there so that's actually our on 16
so just here so what we're going to do
is we know that this whole length here
all the way across our take our on 16
which is equal to 15 are on 16 so that's
what that length is equal to now what
about this long guy here well again here
this distance from here to here is going
to be at our own 4 and all of these are
on 2 are on 2 plus r2 plus r1 2 plus our
own - so that's going to be R plus R so
that's 2 R plus R on 4 so what we've got
here then so this whole length here
that's huge 9r on for now what we want
to do is that we've got Pythagoras's
theorem and we worked out this length
and this length we can work out the
hypotenuse from this o which is the
center of the circle inversion all the
way to this center here of this blue
circle when you work that out that comes
to 39 on
sixteen are now we actually want to know
the distance Oh to be dashed because we
know that will invert right back to this
small circle and we also want to know Oh
- OH - but let's do this one first so we
know that o to B dash is equal to 39 on
16 are plus the radius of the small
circle which is are on 16 so that equals
this Oh a so OAS over here we're going
back from this by our on 16 we're going
back by the radius so it looks like this
39 on 16 our take are on 16 same
denominators so 39 so we end up getting
38 on 16 are now we want to invert these
so we want to take o to be - back to be
okay so let's do that
so o to be when we invert this we end up
getting 16 on 40 ah okay
and we do the same thing with OH - a -
we bring it back to the tiny little
circle there and that means either the a
is this inverted okay and then we end up
getting 8 on 19 are now we've got out of
the a out of the B we know they passes
through the center so we know if we go
oh a take o be we will get the diameter
of this small circle and that happens to
make it 2 so that's that take that which
ends up being 2 on 95r
because the radius is half the diameter
so the radius here of this small circle
so radius of small circle equals one on
95r so we know that the original circle
if we divide by 95 will give us that
radius which means this is 1 1 95